In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for June 23, on which we commemorate our righteous mother
Audrey, Ethel Drita of Ely.
Our holy mother Audrey, Ethel Drita, was born at Exning and Suffolk to the good King
Anna of East Anglia, and his wife Heras Witha, the sister of St. Hilda of Whitby.
King Anna and his wife had two sons, Adolf and German, and five daughters, Ethel Drita,
Sex Berga, Ethel Berga, Seth Rida and With Berga.
All of whom are counted as saints of the Church.
After the death of Anna in battle against the pagan King Penda of Mercia in 654, his wife
received the monastic tonsure and went to live in a monastery near Paris.
In about 652, Ethel Drita was given in marriage by her father to Tonbert, the alderman of South
Jairus, who gave her the Isle of Ely as a dowry.
He was at that time 16 years old and she 30, but Tonbert soon died, leaving Ethel Drita
still a virgin.
The saint then trusted her estate to her faithful steward, Oven, unprepared to receive the
monastic tonsure.
However, her uncle Ethel Wold wanted her to marry King Egfrid of Northumbria.
Again, she submitted to the marriage, but remained a virgin.
King Egfrid made great efforts to persuade her to change her mind.
Saint Wilfrid of York, who was a confidant of the virgin, told Saint Bede that the king
had promised him land and money if he could persuade his wife to consummate the marriage.
Eventually, after 12 years of unconsumated marriage, Egfrid exceeded to her repeated
requests and allowed the Holy Virgin to receive the monastic tonsure at the hands of
Saint Wilfrid in the monastery of Coltingham.
The abyss of the monastery at that time was Saint Eba.
However, the king changed his mind and set out for Coltingham with the intention of bringing
back Ethel Dreda, Thomas of Ely, writes,
The queen, going forth secretly with two handmaids of God, Sawina and Sawara, came to a lofty
hill situated not far from the monastery which she ascended.
There the sea leaving its natural channel and pouring out its waters abundantly, surrounded
the hill on which the Holy Virgin had taken refuge, and so we are told by the inhabitant
of the place, for seven whole days while they continued in prayer and fasting, the tide
protected them, and what is still more wonderful, forgetting its natural eb, it terried there
as long as the king remained.
And so the handmaiden of Christ secured on her rocky eminence escaped the wrath of the king,
and suffered no harm from him.
Egfrid then withdrew and took another wife, Edmund Berger.
Continuing on her journey to Ely, Ethel Dreda lay down in a quiet resting place sprinkled
with flowers of many colors, and fresh with sweet scented grasses.
Unawakening she found that her staff, which she had fixed in the ground at her side, dead
and dry, had put forth branches, clothed with green bark and bearing leaves.
She then left it in the ground and it grew to become a large ash tree.
The place where it grew came to be called Ethel Dreda's Stoe.
Passing on through winteringham and alftham, where she built a church, the saint came to
her domain of Ely in 672.
At first the saint wanted to rebuild the half-ruined church built by St. Felix at Kratendun.
But then she decided to build a new monastery a mile away, near the river, where the cathedral
now stands.
The foundation was laid in 673.
It was financed by her brother St. Adolf, and the architect was St. Wilfred.
When it was completed, Wilfred installed her as the first Abbas.
She was like a mother to her nuns, training them by the good example she herself provided
of the monastic life.
The venerable bead writes that she had only one meal a day, and was a great lover of solitary
prayer and wore woolen garments.
She would seldom bathe except for on the eaves of great feasts, and then she would first
bathe all the others in the convent, and wait on them as a servant, before washing herself
last.
Men and women of noble families would place themselves under her guidance, and bring their
children to the monastery for their education.
She worked many miracles, and demons would flee, not only when she was present or spoke,
but even at the mere invocation of her name when she was absent.
The Saint prophesied not only that she would die of the plague, but also the number of those
in the monastery who would die of the same disease.
She was afflicted by a large tumor growing on her throat, for which she earnestly thanked
God, saying, I know for certain that I very much deserve to be afflicted with this suffering
in my neck.
For in my youth I adorned myself with many neck chains, and now I think God in his justice
is cleansing me of my sin.
For now I have this swelling which shines instead of the gold, and this scorching heat instead
of the sparkling gems.
There was a certain doctor there by the name of Sinifirth, who lanced the tumor, and for
a time the saint's condition improved, but the pain returned, and on the third day, on June
23, in the year 679, she reposed in peace.
She was buried as she had commanded, in the cemetery, in a plain wooden coffin.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.